I can describe the furniture store in one word-- shiny. Shiny purple leather sofas, iridescent mirrored pictures of the sphinx, and King Tut, and panthers, chandeliers and ornamental elephants made of glass and mirror.
我可以把那家家具店用一个词来形容——闪亮。闪亮的紫色真皮沙发，画着狮身人面像和图坦卡蒙法王的虹彩镜面画，还有黑豹、吊灯，以及用玻璃和镜子制成的装饰大象。
Look at that, the china, this thing. These sofas I like over here, I'll show you.
看那个，瓷器，还有这个。这边的沙发我挺喜欢的，我给你看看。
Claudia Perez and I stopped into the store while we were working on a radio story in between interviews. We were on 26th Street in her neighborhood, Little Village, one of Chicago's big Mexican neighborhoods.
克劳迪娅·佩雷斯和我是在做一个广播故事的间隙顺便进店看看的。当时我们在她住的社区——小村，也就是芝加哥主要的墨西哥裔社区之一，位于第26街。
This white sofa. And there's a little table shaped like a piano, and there's glass.
这个白色沙发。还有一张钢琴形状的小桌子，上面有玻璃。
And the piano table is all mirror.
那张钢琴桌全是镜面的。
Is all mirror. And the glass table and glass chairs.
全是镜子的。还有那张玻璃桌子和玻璃椅子。
With glass legs on the glass table.
玻璃桌子底下还有玻璃桌腿。
It's beautiful.
真漂亮。
Claudia is 19, has done a few stories for our radio show. She's one of those teenagers who's on a perpetual plan for self-improvement, switching from job to job, trying to earn enough to keep paying her way through school, struggling. She and I walked past the shiny living rooms, through the shiny dining rooms, and into a dark and shiny bedroom, where she stopped dead and said, "Oh my god."
克劳迪娅19岁，为我们的广播节目做过几个故事。她是个那种一直在自我提升计划中的年轻人，换了一份又一份工作，努力赚钱支付学费，生活得很挣扎。我和她走过那些闪亮的客厅，穿过闪亮的餐厅，走进一间昏暗但又闪亮的卧室，她猛地停住脚步说：“天哪。”
This is-- oh my god. Look at this. This is what I want. This is what I'm going to school for.
这就是——天哪。看看这个。这就是我想要的。这就是我努力读书的目标。
We were staring at a bed with mirrored columns that rose from the headboard and lights built in around the baseboard. There was a mirrored chandelier, a matching white-and-mirror bureau and side table with gold-colored handles, all of which matched each other and matched the bed.
我们盯着一张床，床头板立着几根镜面圆柱，床基周围还嵌着灯。还有一盏镜面吊灯，一套配套的白加镜面组合柜，还有带金色把手的边桌，它们彼此成套，也和那张床很搭。
So which parts of this do you like?
那你最喜欢其中的哪些部分？
Everything. I like the rug, the little Chinese rug, the chests. Oh, it's just so nice. I shouldn't have come in here. This is what I'm going to have. I'm gonna have myself a nice house.
全部。我喜欢那块地毯，那块小小的中式地毯，还有那些柜子。哦，真是太好了。我不该进来的。这就是我未来要拥有的。我要给自己弄个漂亮的房子。
She tells me her family's always rented. Her dream is to own a house, filled with furniture like this. We walked from room to room, looking at gaudy lamps, and cabinets, and chairs. And finally, Claudia turned to me and asked, "So, which do you like best?" and looked into my eyes.
她告诉我她家里一直都在租房住。她的梦想就是拥有一套房子，里面摆满这样的家具。我们从一个房间走到另一个房间，看着那些花哨的灯具、柜子和椅子。最后，克劳迪娅转过身问我：“那么，你最喜欢哪一个？”然后直视着我的眼睛。
Now I grew up in the Jewish suburbs outside of Baltimore. I am no stranger to furniture like this. It filled the bright, lime-green, carpeted living rooms of a good number of the people who I grew up with and loved. I have personally had as many big moments in my life while sitting around glass-top tables with shiny, mirrored legs as anyone you have ever met. I've had important conversations leaning on iridescent silver pillows, my feet on super long, white shag carpet. I feel at home in this setting.
我是在巴尔的摩郊区的犹太社区长大的。我对这样的家具并不陌生。它填满了许多我从小长大并深爱的人家里那种明亮、嫩绿色地毯铺就的客厅。我也曾像你见过的任何人一样，坐在闪亮的镜面桌腿的玻璃桌旁，经历过人生中许多重要的时刻。我曾斜靠在虹彩银色的靠垫上，双脚踩在长长厚厚的白色毛绒地毯上，进行过重要的谈话。在这个环境里，我感到很自在。
But-- and I say this meaning no disrespect-- I have not chosen this for my adult life. It is not my dream. So when Claudia asked, "Which do you like best?" I paused, and I said, "I like the plainer stuff." And she looked at me, did not say anything.
但是——我这样说并没有不敬的意思——我并没有选择这样的生活作为成年后的归宿。这不是我的梦想。所以当克劳迪娅问“你最喜欢哪一个”时，我停顿了一下，说：“我喜欢款式简约的那些。”她看着我，什么也没说。
I think that this answer just did not make sense to her. My taste does not make much sense to her. She and I were in that situation, that situation that two people find themselves in now and then, that situation of thinking, "Yeah, your dream, my nightmare."
我觉得这个回答对她来说根本没意义。我的品味对她而言毫无头绪。我和她当时陷入了那种困境，那种人们偶尔会遇到的境地，也就是心里想着：“没错，你的梦想，就是我的噩梦。”
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a wide variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Your Dream, My Nightmare. Act One, Noise. A serious-minded music critic gets sent on her nightmare vacation to Rock-n-Roll Fantasy Camp. Act Two, Color, in which an interracial couple traveling through Tennessee cannot agree on one tourist destination, an antebellum mansion plantation.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《这一美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，并带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是《你的梦想，我的噩梦》。第一幕，《噪音》。一位严肃的音乐评论家被派去她心目中的噩梦度假地——摇滚梦想训练营。第二幕，《色彩》，讲述一对跨种族夫妇在田纳西州旅行时，无法就一个旅游目的地——一座战前的庄园种植园——达成一致。
Act Three, Motion, in which radio producer Jay Allison decides that all the news stories he ever covers are essentially one story, one story whose theme is-- do we even have to tell you? Act Four, Blood. Some of the biggest your-dream-my-nightmare scenarios occur when parents try to impose their dream upon their children. Writer David Sedaris provides us with a case example on the golf course. Stay with us.
第三幕，《运动》，广播制作人杰伊·艾利森认为他报道的所有新闻故事本质上都是同一个故事，一个主题是——我们还需要说吗？第四幕，《血缘》。一些最大的“你的梦想，我的噩梦”场景发生在父母试图将自己的梦想强加给孩子的时候。作家大卫·塞达里斯将为我们提供一个高尔夫球场上的案例。请继续收听。
Act One, Noise. Well, here is someone's fantasy. A cocktail party about 7:00 in the evening in an old hotel in Miami Beach, where, by the swimming pool, there's Bruce Springsteen, draft beer in hand, making polite small talk. Actually, it's not Bruce. It's his old side men, Clarence Clemons  and Nils Lofgren. Oh, and there's Billy Joel. Well, not really Billy Joel. It's Billy Joel's drummer, Liberty DeVitto.
第一幕，《噪音》。好吧，这里有人的一场幻梦。晚上7点左右，迈阿密海滩的一家老酒店里，在游泳池边，布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀手里拿着生啤酒，在礼貌地寒暄。实际上，那不是布鲁斯，而是他以前的伴奏乐手克拉伦斯·克莱蒙斯和尼尔斯·洛夫格伦。哦，还有比利·乔尔。好吧，其实也不是比利·乔尔，而是比利·乔尔的鼓手利伯蒂·德维托。
This is Rock-n-Roll Fantasy Camp. It really exists. And this April, 33 campers got their dream, to come to the Eden Roc Hotel in Florida for five days, drink nervously through cocktail parties like this one, play nervously in celebrity jam sessions. All in all, for most of them, a dream come true.
这就是摇滚梦想训练营。它是真实存在的。今年四月，33名学员实现了他们的梦想，来到佛罗里达的伊甸园洛克酒店度过五天，在像这样的鸡尾酒会上紧张地喝着酒，在名人的果酱音乐会上紧张地演奏。总而言之，对他们大多数人来说，梦想成真了。
Well, Sarah Vowell has different dreams. Sarah is one of our contributing editors and a music writer for Spin, The Village Voice, and Salon. She dropped in on Rock-n-Roll Fantasy Camp.
嗯，莎拉·沃威尔有不同的梦想。莎拉是我们的一位特约编辑，也是《Spin》、《乡村之声》和《Salon》杂志的音乐撰稿人。她也去参加了摇滚梦想训练营。
My rock and roll fantasy is this, that occasionally, every now and then, a song I like comes on the radio. It's a simple dream, I know. And every so often, once or twice a year, it actually comes true.
我的摇滚梦想是这样的：偶尔，哪怕只是偶尔，我喜欢的歌会在电台里播放。我知道，这只是个简单的梦想。而且每隔一段时间，一年一两次，它真的会成真。
I get all I need from pop music song by song. And that's how I like it best, two or three minutes of speed or sorrow coming out of speakers with so much something that the world stops cold. I rarely daydreamed of befriending my rock idols. Maybe it's because I tend to admire cranks. Like I really want to toast in the New Year with Jerry Lee Lewis, or go shoe shopping with Courtney Love, or build sand castles with a peach like Lou Reed.
我从流行音乐中获取我所需要的一切，一首歌接一首歌。我最喜欢这种方式，两三分钟的节奏感或忧伤从音箱里传出，世界仿佛瞬间静止。我很少梦想能和我的摇滚偶像交朋友。也许是因为我倾向于崇拜怪人。比如，我真的想和杰里·李·刘易斯一起庆祝新年，或者和考特妮·洛芙一起去买鞋，或者和卢·里德那样的人一起堆沙堡。
My musical heroes are mostly snotty weirdos who didn't become famous because of their social graces. Just because I have them in my heart doesn't mean I want them in my life. So the very idea of spending five whole days couped up in Miami, taking guitar workshops from moldy rock big shots and paying upwards of $3,000 to do it at something called Rock-n-Roll Fantasy Camp isn't my fantasy. Try my worst nightmare.
我的音乐英雄大多是些傲慢的怪胎，他们出名不是因为有什么社交技巧。仅仅因为我心里爱戴他们，并不代表我想让他们进入我的生活。所以，花费3000多美元把自己关在迈阿密五天，从那些发霉的摇滚大腕那里学习吉他课程，去参加什么所谓的摇滚梦想训练营，这根本不是我的幻梦。这简直是我的噩梦。
My rock and roll fantasy is to get those lessons from Mark Farner, and Leslie West, and Felix Cavaliere.
我的摇滚梦想是向马克·法纳、莱斯利·韦斯特和菲利克斯·卡瓦列里学习。
Hopefully, you have no idea who these people are. And you never did if the years 1970 to '75 are underrepresented in your record collection in both the chronological and spiritual senses. Mark Farner is the scary, born-again, lead guitarist of Grand Funk Railroad. You know, Grand Funk Railroad?
希望你不知道这些人是谁。如果1970年到1975年的唱片在你的收藏中无论是从年代还是精神意义上都处于缺失状态，那你肯定没听过。马克·法纳是“大函数铁路”乐队（Grand Funk Railroad）那位可怕的、重生的主音吉他手。你知道“大函数铁路”乐队吗？
[MUSIC - "WE'RE AN AMERICAN BAND" BY GRAND FUNK RAILROAD]
[音乐 - “We're an American Band” by Grand Funk Railroad]
Guitarist Leslie West played Woodstock with his band, Mountain.
吉他手莱斯利·韦斯特曾随他的乐队“山峦”（Mountain）参加过伍德斯托克音乐节。
[MUSIC - "MISSISSIPPI QUEEN" BY MOUNTAIN]
[音乐 - “Mississippi Queen” by Mountain]
And Felix Cavaliere's from The Young Rascals. I actually like this song.
而菲利克斯·卡瓦列里来自“年轻流氓”（The Young Rascals）乐队。我其实挺喜欢这首歌的。
[MUSIC - "GOOD LOVIN'" BY THE YOUNG RASCALS]
[音乐 - “Good Lovin'” by The Young Rascals]
Bet you didn't think you'd be hearing these songs when you turned on public radio today, did ya?
打赌你没想到今天打开公共广播时会听到这些歌吧？
Anybody who's here is from my '70 dreams.
在这里的任何人都是从我的70年代梦想中走出来的。
My fantasy for this camp would be to have Nils Lofgren teach me a few tricks in open G.
我参加这个训练营的梦想是让尼尔斯·洛夫格伦教我几个G调的弹奏技巧。
I guess I would compare my voice to that of Lou Gramm of Foreigner. And there he is, right there.
我想我会把我的声音比作“外籍人”乐队（Foreigner）的卢·格拉姆。他就在那里，就在那儿。
And who are these rock and roll fans, whose dreams, whose entire conception of rock and roll is so different from my own? Joe, who markets sound equipment in Detroit; Connie and Maxine, sisters from Minneapolis who left their husbands and kids back home; and Rob, the math teacher from Long Island who heard about the camp on Howard Stern's radio show.
那么这些人是谁呢？这些摇滚迷，他们对摇滚乐的全部构想与我如此不同？乔，在底特律推销音响设备；康妮和玛克辛，来自明尼阿波利斯的姐妹，把丈夫和孩子留在家里；还有罗伯，长岛的数学老师，从霍华德·斯特恩的电台节目里听到了这个训练营。
I love famous-- I like famous people. I love to see and meet famous people. And this is hanging out with famous people.
我爱名人——我喜欢名人。我爱看名人、见名人。而这就是和名人待在一起。
Just take a beat like that when you're in G. You can keep the low string on the third fret. Just pump it with your thumb.
当你弹G调时，就这样敲击一下。你可以把低音弦留在第三品。用大拇指弹奏即可。
That's Nils Lofgren's guitar workshop, probably the most low-key, sensible seminar of the camp. He's a kind, respectful man. And even though he knows what he's doing, he doesn't get all curlicued about it. He pumps out a chug-a-lug rhythm, advising his students to try to "stay in the back pocket of the beat" and to "think like a drummer, real rhythmic."
那是尼尔斯·洛夫格伦的吉他研讨课，大概是训练营里最平易近人、最理性的讲座。他是个善良、懂礼貌的人。尽管他技术精湛，但他并没有显摆什么。他弹奏出一种有力的节奏，建议学生尽量“保持在节拍的后方”，并且“像鼓手一样思考，真正有节奏感”。
Watching them lurch along doesn't look like any fantasy I've ever had. It would almost be boring except that watching nervous people in any given situation is always at least slightly engaging. And also, as the only girl in the room, I keep cracking up, watching an arrangement of men sitting in a circle, stroking their instruments. A phrase comes to mind, one I'm not sure I can say on the radio, but includes the word "jerk."
看着他们笨拙地跟着弹，这看起来不像是我曾有过的任何幻梦。这简直快要让人睡着了，除了在任何情况下观察紧张的人总是至少有一点吸引力之外。而且，作为房间里唯一的女孩，我看着一群男人们围坐成一圈，抚摸着他们的乐器，我一直在偷笑。一个词浮现在脑海里，我不确定能不能在广播里说，但里面包含了一个“混蛋”（jerk）这个词。
Usually, what I do is when my hand starts cramping, I'm getting really frustrated and angry, stop and play something that's fun. And if you learn major and minor scales--
通常，当我的手开始抽筋时，我会感到非常沮丧和生气，停下来弹些有趣的东西。如果你学习大调和小调音阶的话——
When Lofgren mentions scales, it seems like everyone can play the do-re-mi one. But no one knows the blues scale he plays, the most basic downward spiral imaginable. It seems like something you should be paying Kenny down at the Guitar Shack $10 to teach you instead of bothering the man who pinch-hits for Bruce Springsteen and Neil Young.
当洛夫格伦提到音阶时，似乎每个人都会弹“Do-Re-Mi”那个版本。但没有人知道他弹的蓝调音阶，那是你能想象出的最基本的向下螺旋音。这看起来像你本该花10块钱去吉他小屋找肯尼教你的东西，而不是去打扰那位替布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和尼尔·杨伴奏的大腕。
Lofgren informs the class that he's going to take a solo, and they should try and "keep the rhythm strong for me." Good luck. What's apparent isn't so much the gaping difference between skill or the lack of it, but rather the chasm between confidence and self-doubt. Lofgren plays tough, spare riffs and looks so easy-does-it cool. Meanwhile, all the campers around him are tapping their feet like they're marching off to the front lines, and all their eyes are fixed on their fingers, trying not to screw up.
洛夫格伦告诉班里他要来一段独奏，让他们尽量“为我保持强劲的节奏”。祝他们好运。显而易见的不是技术水平或缺乏技术的差距，而是自信与自我怀疑之间的鸿沟。洛夫格伦弹奏出强硬、简洁的旋律，看起来酷毙了。与此同时，他周围所有的学员都在跺着脚，就像正要去前线一样，他们所有的眼睛都盯着自己的手指，努力不要搞砸。
This seems like a good moment to pause and talk about what is and isn't rock and roll. As a believer in the anyone-can-do-it, all-or-nothing-at-all ethic of punk rock, I think real music's not about technique, or virtuosity, or knowing your scales. It's about believing in what you have to say and wanting to say it so badly that you'll scream your guts out if that's what it takes to get people to listen. Later on, when I ask Lofgren if he met anyone in the camp he thought had real talent or anything to say, his answer was gracious, diplomatic.
这似乎是一个停下来讨论什么是摇滚、什么不是摇滚的好时机。作为朋克摇滚中那种“谁都能做、破釜沉舟”精神的信徒，我认为真正的音乐不在于技术、精湛的技艺，也不在于你知道多少音阶。它在于相信你要说的话，并且非常想把它说出来，如果你需要尖叫才能让人们听见，那你就会声嘶力竭地喊。后来，当我在问洛夫格伦是否在训练营遇到过真正有才华或有话要说的人时，他的回答既客气又外交辞令。
Well, I heard a love for music in everybody.
嗯，我在每个人身上都听到了对音乐的热爱。
Over the course of the camp, I'll sit through nearly a dozen such seminars. And it becomes painfully obvious that rock and roll high school is a lot like real high school. Subject matter doesn't matter as much as the personality of the teacher. Everyone wants to be Lofgren's pet. But Rick Derringer leads his guitar session like the nitpick who takes points off for bad penmanship.
在训练营期间，我会参加近十场这样的研讨会。于是痛苦地发现，摇滚高中和真正的高中非常相似。课程本身并不重要，重要的是老师的个性。每个人都想成为洛夫格伦的宠儿。但瑞克·德林格带他的吉他课就像个因为学生字迹潦草而扣分的琐碎挑剔者。
Let's see if everybody's on the list. John Ralder? Is he here? That's you. John, how do you do? Marian Green?
让我们看看谁在名单上。约翰·拉尔德？他在吗？就是你。约翰，你好吗？玛丽安·格林？
She's not here.
她没来。
Is not here today. Marian Green. Peter--
今天没来。玛丽安·格林。彼得——
Yes, Derringer is the only instructor who actually took attendance. Attendance. After showing off for a while, he proceeds to spend nearly 10 whole minutes spreading crackpot ideas, such as--
是的，德林格是唯一一位真的点名的导师。考勤。在炫耀了一会儿之后，他开始花近10分钟的时间传播一些怪论，比如——
And I like my guitar to be clean. I find that if you get the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] grungy, and stuff in between the frets, and dirt up here, all of a sudden your arm starts sticking up here. And it just doesn't feel the same. I see people sometimes playing, and their guitars are all dirty, and the strings are all out of whack, and things are real high. I think the most important thing is making your guitar playable. So clean the thing. Clean it real good. I do things like Pledge. Pledge. Pledge. You know why?
我喜欢我的吉他保持干净。我发现如果你的品丝之间积了污垢，上面有灰尘，突然间你的手臂就会粘在上面。感觉就不一样了。我有时看到人们在弹琴，他们的吉他很脏，琴弦走调，琴弦位置很高。我认为最重要的是让你的吉他保持好演奏的状态。所以把它擦干净。一定要彻底擦干净。我甚至用碧丽珠（Pledge）。碧丽珠。碧丽珠。知道为什么吗？
I can't imagine anyone I admire talking this way. He is literally holding up a can of furniture polish like he's doing a TV commercial. Would Keith Richards display a spray bottle of 409? Would Neil Young, asked to discuss his craft, even use the word "cleanliness?"
我无法想象任何我敬佩的人会这样说话。他真的举着一罐家具抛光剂，就像在拍电视广告一样。基思·理查兹会展示一瓶409清洁喷雾吗？尼尔·杨在被问及创作工艺时，会用“清洁度”这个词吗？
With Pledge.
用碧丽珠。
And the thing is while I was gagging at Derringer's dopiness, most of the campers found him hilarious. In fact, these people sat through their workshops, and jam sessions, and lunch buffets with these serene smiles. And watching them, I got jealous. To me, music has always been an ideological battleground, where you hate-hate your enemies and save-save your friends. To them, music seems like this uncomplicated part of their lives that simply makes them happy.
而且，当我对德林格的愚蠢感到反胃时，大多数学员却觉得他滑稽可笑。事实上，这些人带着平和的微笑坐着听课、参加果酱音乐会和自助午餐。看着他们，我感到了嫉妒。对我来说，音乐一直是一个意识形态的战场，你会痛恨敌人并拯救朋友。而对他们来说，音乐似乎是生活中简单的一部分，只是让他们感到快乐。
So I'm just here for fun, and to have some fun, and to get some exposure to some of the instruments. And I really just like the music.
所以我只是为了好玩，为了获得乐趣，接触一下这些乐器。我真的只是喜欢音乐而已。
For me, the problem with hanging around the campers was this. They were so gosh darn nice, sweet even. My job as a grumpy commentator would've been a lot easier to stomach if they'd been the self-satisfied yuppies I'd come to make fun of. But they kind of ruined my fun by being so likable. I couldn't even mutter Peter Frampton insults under my breath without feeling guilty. And you know you're in some kind of parallel universe when the most punk rock person there is the reporter from Forbes.
对我来说，待在这些学员周围的问题是这样的。他们太可爱了，甚至可以说是甜美。如果他们是我去嘲讽的那种自以为是的雅皮士，我作为一名愤世嫉俗的评论员的工作就会容易得多。但他们因为太讨人喜欢了，反而毁了我的乐趣。我连小声嘀咕关于彼得·弗兰普顿的讽刺话语时都会感到内疚。你知道，当你发现那里最朋克的人竟然是《福布斯》杂志的记者时，你就知道自己身处一个平行的宇宙了。
The campers came all this way. They paid all this money. It's their dream to meet these rock stars. So when they finally get to hang out with them, what do they talk about? What's at the heart of their dream? I cornered Joe, a guitarist from Detroit, one night after dinner.
这些学员大老远跑来。他们付了这么多钱。见到摇滚明星是他们的梦想。所以当他们终于有机会和这些人在一起时，他们谈论些什么呢？他们梦想的核心是什么？一天晚饭后，我把底特律的吉他手乔堵住了。
So Joe, when I was pulling back up to the hotel, I saw you getting out of a limo.
乔，刚才我开车回酒店时，看见你从一辆豪华轿车上下来。
It's the only way to travel.
这是唯一的旅行方式。
And whose limo were you traveling in?
你坐的是谁的车？
That was with Rick Derringer and also Lou Gramm.
那是和瑞克·德林格还有卢·格拉姆一起的。
You went out to dinner?
你们去吃晚餐了？
Yeah, we went out to dinner at Gloria Estefan's restaurant.
是的，我们去了葛洛丽亚·伊斯特芬的餐厅吃饭。
And so what was that like, having dinner with those guys?
那么，和那些家伙一起吃饭是什么感觉？
They were so congenial. We had a sing-a-along in the car. We were doing some Foreigner songs. And we were doing "Hang On Sloopy." And it was all a capella. And our little kids all joined in too to help out. So it was a group thing, the wives, the kids, the guys.
他们非常合群。我们在车里一起唱歌。我们唱了一些“外籍人”乐队的歌。我们还唱了“Hang On Sloopy”。都是清唱的。我们的小孩也加入了进来一起帮忙。所以这是一个集体活动，妻子们、孩子们，还有男人们。
"Hang On Sloopy." I'll admit, I love that song, which came in handy for my sanity. Since Derringer played on it a million years ago with his old band, The McCoys, it was constant jam session fodder at the camp. And one night, all the campers gathered on stage to perform it with Derringer singing lead, sparking one of the rare moments when the music they made together felt real and sounded exciting to them and to me.
“Hang On Sloopy”。我得承认，我很爱那首歌，这对我保持理智很有帮助。因为德林格一万年前曾用他以前的乐队“麦考伊”演奏过这首歌，它是训练营里永恒的果酱音乐材料。一天晚上，所有的学员聚集在舞台上，和德林格一起演唱，点燃了那难得的瞬间之一，当他们一起创作音乐时，感觉既真实又让人兴奋，不论是对他们还是对我而言。
That kind of excitement didn't last. For every second of participatory, palatable noise, there were three hours of rock star war stories. And while I gave myself headaches from rolling my eyes, the campers ate these anecdotes up, egging on people like keyboardist Bobby Mayo to fill their heads with behind-the-scenes insights into Frampton Comes Alive, an album they had apparently memorized note for yucky note.
那种兴奋并没有持续下去。每有一秒钟可以共同参与的、好听的噪音，就有三个小时的摇滚明星战争故事。当我因为翻白眼而感到头痛时，学员们却贪婪地吸收着这些轶事，怂恿像键盘手鲍比·梅奥这样的人往他们脑子里灌输关于专辑《Frampton Comes Alive》的幕后见解，那可是他们似乎把每一个音符都背下来的烂专辑。
We had gotten together as a group in January of that year, '75. And we started touring. We were opening for everybody. We opened for ZZ Top, J. Geils, Rod Stewart, Black Sabbath. You name it, we opened for these guys.
我们是在那年的1月组成了团队，75年。然后我们开始巡演。我们给所有人暖场。我们给ZZ Top、J. Geils、罗德·斯图尔特、黑色安息日暖场。你随便说一个，我们都给他们暖过场。
So that was all done as an opening act?
所以这些都是作为暖场乐队完成的？
Pretty much. About 75% of it was done as an opening act.
差不多。大约75%是作为暖场乐队完成的。
And if you think listening to these tall tales once was boring, try twice. On the camp's last day, goofball Mike Love of The Beach Boys showed up. Every time he opened his mouth was a defamation of The Beach Boys' greatness. He insulted his audience by telling the same stories at his afternoon lecture as he did on stage the very same night. Here's the afternoon.
如果你觉得听一次这些吹牛的故事很无聊，那就试试听两次吧。在训练营的最后一天，白痴迈克·洛夫（海滩男孩乐队）出现了。他每次开口都是在抹黑海滩男孩的伟大。他在下午讲座上说的故事和当天晚上舞台上讲的竟然一模一样，简直是在侮辱听众。这是下午的。
I was in India. McCartney's in one bungalow, I'm in the other. We used to have conversations up on the roof at night, under the stars. It was pretty cool. He said, "Mike, you oughta take more care with your album covers." He was the mastermind of Sgt. Pepper's.
当时我在印度。麦卡特尼在一个平房里，我在另一个。我们晚上常坐在屋顶上，在星空下聊天。挺酷的。他说：“迈克，你应该在专辑封面上多花点心思。”他是《胡椒军曹》的策划者。
Here's the evening.
这是晚上的。
He would say, "Mike, you should take more care of your album covers." This is the guy who conceived Sgt. Pepper's.
他说：“迈克，你应该在专辑封面上多花点心思。”这就是构想出《胡椒军曹》的那个家伙。
Afternoon.
下午。
"So sensible you should say that." I said, "Yeah, well, with all due respect, we've always paid more attention to what goes in the album than on the cover," which is a touche remark, I have to admit.
“你能这么说真是太有见地了。”我说，“嗯，恕我直言，比起封面，我们一直更关注专辑里的内容。”这真是一个机智的回答，我得承认。
Evening.
晚上。
So I said, "Paul, we always took more care of what went in them." It was a [? touche event. ?] You got to forgive me.
所以我说：“保罗，我们一直更关注里面装了什么。”这真是一个[？机智的时刻]。你得原谅我。
And the sad thing is some people laughed both times. Maybe they were just being nice. They were nice people.
可悲的是，竟然有人两次都笑了。也许他们只是出于礼貌。他们确实是很好的人。
Then it hit me. Sitting there watching them drink in all those, no doubt, enhanced rock star tall tales with such obvious glee was like watching new myths being born. Because anyone with relatives can tell you, rehashed, souped-up stories are not the sole property of washed-up rock stars. I bet Joe from Detroit's going to be telling his Lou Gramm limo story for at least as long as Mike Love's been dissing Paul McCartney.
然后我意识到了。坐在那里看着他们带着明显的喜悦贪婪地喝下那些毫无疑问是被美化过的摇滚明星吹牛故事，就像看着新的神话诞生。因为任何有亲戚的人都能告诉你，重新包装、加油添醋的故事并不是落魄摇滚明星的专属产物。我敢打赌，底特律的乔讲那个卢·格拉姆的豪车故事的时间，至少会像迈克·洛夫诋毁保罗·麦卡特尼的时间一样长。
And I actually found this kind of reassuring. Once the camp ended, I could go back to my beloved punky malcontents. My nightmare was over the minute I boarded the plane home. But I knew that for the spouses and children and co-workers of the campers, the nightmare had just begun.
而且我真的觉得这挺让人宽心的。训练营结束后，我可以回到我心爱的朋克愤青圈子里了。噩梦在我登上回程飞机的瞬间就结束了。但我知道，对于学员们的配偶、孩子和同事来说，噩梦才刚刚开始。
Sarah Vowell is the author of the book Radio On and a music columnist for the online magazine Salon. She first wrote about Rock-n-Roll Fantasy Camp for Request Magazine.
莎拉·沃威尔是《Radio On》一书的作者，也是网络杂志《Salon》的音乐专栏作家。她最初为《Request》杂志撰写了关于摇滚梦想训练营的文章。
And Sarah?
莎拉？
Yes, Ira.
在的，艾拉。
You said at the beginning of your story that your own rock and roll fantasy is that occasionally, every now and then, a song you like would actually come on the radio.
你在故事开头说，你自己的摇滚梦想是偶尔、哪怕偶尔也会有一首你喜欢的歌在电台里播放。
So I did. Ira, can you make my dream come true?
是的，我是这么说的。艾拉，你能让我的梦想成真吗？
Indeed, I can, Sarah Vowell. What song would you like to hear on the radio?
当然可以，莎拉·沃威尔。你想在电台听到什么歌？
Well, there's this song that I played in my hotel room every night during the camp to remind me of my ideal, the thing I was looking for. It's the sixth song. This is by a little band called Sleater-Kinney. The song's called "Words and Guitar."
嗯，有这样一首歌，在训练营期间我每晚都在酒店房间里播放，以此提醒我心目中的理想，我一直在寻找的东西。这是第六首歌。这来自一个小乐队，叫Sleater-Kinney。这首歌叫《Words and Guitar》。
[MUSIC - "WORDS AND GUITAR" BY SLEATER-KINNEY]
[音乐 - “Words and Guitar” by Sleater-Kinney]
Why this song?
为什么是这首歌？
Because it's about the two most elemental things of rock and roll, words  and guitar. And the way the band sings and plays the song, it's like those are the only two things you'll ever need.
因为它关于摇滚乐最基本的两样东西：歌词和吉他。而乐队演唱和演奏这首歌的方式，让你觉得那就是你唯一需要的两样东西。
Act Two, Colors. Well, that feeling of your dream, my nightmare can happen with the people you're closest to, not just strangers. For instance, Marvin Tate was traveling with his wife, Lucy, and their two-year-old toddler, Ivy, to visit his sister in Tennessee. And they could not agree on what sightseeing they wanted to do.
第二幕，《色彩》。嗯，那种你的梦想、我的噩梦的感觉，不仅发生在陌生人之间，也会发生在最亲近的人身上。比如，马文·泰特带着他的妻子露西和两岁的幼儿艾薇，去田纳西州探望他的姐姐。他们无法就想要去哪里观光达成一致。
He wanted to go to the Ernie Tubb country music store. That is her nightmare. She wanted to go to the Belle Meade plantation. That was his nightmare.
他想去恩尼·塔布的乡村音乐商店。那是她的噩梦。她想去贝尔米德庄园。那是他的噩梦。
He's black. She's white. And he could just not understand what possible interest she could have in this. But she insisted.
他是黑人。她是白人。他简直无法理解她为什么会对此有任何兴趣。但她坚持要去。
I could tell by the determined look on Lucy's face that there wasn't going to be any turning back, not now or ever. Lucy thumbed her way through a travel guide, looking for directions to the Belle Meade plantation. I went inside the gas station to ask the guy sitting behind the register, a beef-jerky-chewing, Snapple-drinking Leon Russell type in overalls, a baseball cap, and a coffee-stained "I hate New Yorkers" T-shirt on. Well, I thought, maybe he'd be too dumb to have ever heard of the Belle Meade. And then I'd be off the hook, and we wouldn't have to go.
我从露西坚定的眼神中看出，我们不会回头了，现在不会，以后也不会。露西翻着一本旅游指南，寻找去贝尔米德庄园的路线。我走进加油站，去问那个坐在收银台后面的人，一个嚼着肉干、喝着Snapple的莱昂·拉塞尔式人物，穿着工装背带裤，戴着棒球帽，身上那件咖啡渍斑斑的“我讨厌纽约人”的T恤。嗯，我想，也许他笨到连贝尔米德庄园都没听说过，那我就解脱了，我们也就不用去了。
"Excuse me, sir. Sir, excuse me. Could you please tell me how to get to the Belle Meade plantation?" How ridiculous I must have sounded. Plaaaaaan-tation. A contemporary brother, man, asking for directions on how to get to some plantation turned museum.
“不好意思，先生。先生，打扰一下。你能告诉我怎么去贝尔米德庄园吗？”我听起来肯定很荒唐。庄——园（Plaaaaaan-tation）。一个现代兄弟，伙计，竟然在问路怎么去某个被改成博物馆的种植园。
Back in the car, Lucy drove like a maniac as if there was a pot of gold at the end of our destination. And then there we were, at the old Belle Meade plantation. I looked at my family. It was becoming quite obvious that this trip had taken its toll on me and the way I talked.
回到车里，露西像个疯子一样开车，仿佛在我们的目的地终点有一罐金子。然后我们到了，在那座古老的贝尔米德庄园。我看着我的家人。很明显，这次旅行对我说话的方式产生了影响。
I said to them, "I'm an ooold Negro from the ooold South. And I welcome you here to the ooold Belle Meade. You might recognize me from the ooold Negro League. My name is Sonny Jackson. And this here-- this here is my teary-eyed, mulatto baby, Ivy. And seated next to her is the oooold massa's daughter, Lucy."
我对他们说：“我是一个来自老南方的老黑人。欢迎你们来到老贝尔米德。你们可能在老黑人联盟里见过我。我叫桑尼·杰克逊。而这位——这位是我热泪盈眶的混血宝宝，艾薇。坐在她旁边的是老庄园主的女儿，露西。”
I took a deep breath, and swallowed, and climbed out the car. Dammit, I thought, here I go again. The only brother at an all-white affair.
我深吸一口气，咽了口唾沫，下了车。该死，我想，又来了。这是全白人的场合里唯一的兄弟。
At first, no one seemed to notice me. Not until Lucy kissed me on the cheek did all the double- and triple-takes begin. One woman, losing sight of what she was doing, nearly knocked over the torso of a commemoration statue. A balding man, who looked like an employee, walked into an old barnyard, quickly stepped back out, took off his glasses, and wiped them clean with his shirttail. It was that brief moment that I knew. I knew that I had to change history. No more camouflaging and going with the program, so that everything could be hokey-dokey OK.
起初，没人注意到我。直到露西亲了亲我的脸颊，所有的回头注视才开始。一个女人失去了对自己行为的控制，差点撞倒了一个纪念雕像的躯干。一个秃顶的男人，看起来像个员工，走进一个旧谷仓，迅速退了出来，摘下眼镜，用衬衫下摆擦干净。就在那一瞬间，我知道了。我知道我必须改变历史。不能再为了让一切看起来皆大欢喜而伪装、随波逐流了。
I had made up my mind that whoever that tour guide was going to be that I was going to show them that I wasn't just another token black guy who can take an extra shot, decaf, vanilla latte with no foam. Or the brother who had integrated into the mainstream by marrying someone white. This time, I was determined to drop the bomb, P-Funk style, by asking questions that the other tourists would be too afraid to ask.
我打定主意，不管导游是谁，我都要向他们展示我不仅仅是另一个可以多点一杯不加泡沫的低因香草拿铁的象征性黑人。或者那个通过娶一个白人女性融入主流社会的兄弟。这次，我决心要搞点大动作，用P-Funk的风格，通过提出那些其他游客不敢问的问题来投下一枚炸弹。
Going back in time is going to be cool, the way Mr. Peabody and his boy, Sherman, used to do. The only difference would be that I was not going to be stepping in the time machine. And the past I had to conquer was staring me right in the face.
回到过去会很酷，就像皮博迪先生和他的男孩谢尔曼常做的那样。唯一的区别是我不会踏入时间机器。而我必须征服的过去正盯着我看。
Lucy and I got in line for the tour. I clutched my ticket and whispered in Lucy's ear, "Now you lissen here, Miss Lucy. I's ain't about to go in no massa's house without his permission." Lucy kissed Ivy on the head and said, "Daddy's pretending to be a slave."
露西和我排队等待参观。我攥着票，在露西耳边小声说：“现在听好了，露西小姐。我可不想在没有庄园主允许的情况下进他的房子。”露西亲了亲艾薇的头说：“爸爸在假装当奴隶呢。”
From out of the front door came our tour guide, Gussie, waifish-like with a Scarlett O'Hara number on. "Welcome to the Belle Meade," Gussie said, ringing that tiny bell to gather everybody's attention. "As you can notice from the three magnificent rocking chairs that sit behind me on the porch, the Belle Meade's owners had a lavish appetite for space and anything big. These rocking chairs were all carved by local artisans of the day. They were designed to look like thrones."
前门走出来我们的导游格西，身材瘦小，穿着斯嘉丽·奥哈拉风格的裙子。“欢迎来到贝尔米德，”格西一边摇着那个用来吸引大家注意的小铃铛一边说。“正如你们能从我身后门廊上的那三把宏伟的摇椅上看到的那样，贝尔米德的主人对空间和巨大的东西有着奢华的胃口。这些摇椅都是当时当地的工匠手工雕刻的。它们被设计成看起来像王座的样子。”
Gussie acted like she and the rest of her Civil-War-cladded patriots had the coolest summer job in the world, telling useless historical anecdotes to white tourists, nostalgic for the days of Southern chivalry. She told us stuff about the curtains, china patterns, silverware patterns, carpet patterns. And for some reason-- now, maybe there's something wrong with me-- but for some reason, everyone was eating these trivial tidbits up. I couldn't believe it.
格西表现得就像她和其余穿着内战时期服装的爱国者们拥有一份世界上最酷的暑期工作一样，向那些怀念南方骑士精神时代的白人游客讲述着无用的历史趣事。她告诉我们关于窗帘、瓷器图案、银器图案、地毯图案的事情。而且不知出于什么原因——好吧，也许我有什么毛病——但由于某种原因，每个人都在津津有味地听这些琐事。我简直不敢相信。
One excited tourist, who looked like he had just stepped off the sandy beaches of Miami, shot his hand up in the air. "How did they keep the rodents out the house?" "Why, with a straw broom and lots of cats," responded Gussie. "Why are the walls painted in such pale blues and greens?"
一位看起来像是刚从迈阿密沙滩上走下来的兴奋游客，高高地举起了手。“他们是怎么把老鼠赶出房子的？”“哦，用一把草扫帚和很多猫，”格西回答道。“为什么墙壁要刷成这么浅的蓝色和绿色？”
While everyone continued with these small, trivial facts, it seemed there was one big, important fact of life here that everyone was not talking about. I'll spell it for you. S-L-A-V-E-R-Y. Now does that sound like a four-letter word to you? Thank you.
当每个人都在继续谈论这些微不足道的小事实时，似乎这里有一个这里每个人都不愿谈论的重大生活事实。我给你们拼出来。S-L-A-V-E-R-Y（奴隶制）。现在这听起来像个四个字母的脏词了吗？谢谢。
I knew now that I was in the past. I had gone beyond the past. I was in the ooold South. And there was no turning back. My patience with this Twilight Zone episode was ending. I thought that if I could just figure out the perfect question to ask, well, I could turn this whole thing around, and history would no longer be from Gussie's point of view.
我知道我身处过去。我已经超越了过去。我身处“老南方”。而且没有回头路了。我对这集《阴阳魔界》的耐心已经耗尽了。我想如果我能想出那个完美的问题来问，我就能扭转整个局面，历史将不再只是格西的视角了。
"OK," I'd say, "by the way, Gussie, did General Harding ever rape one of his slaves?" Nah, that would sound more like an accusation more so than an intelligent question. OK, I'd say, "So Gussie, are you the descendants of slave owners? And if so, how did you benefit from it?" No, that sounded too much like a Farrakhan rip-off.
“好吧，”我会说，“顺便问一下，格西，哈丁将军有没有强奸过他的奴隶？”不，那听起来更像是指控而不是聪明的问题。好吧，我会说，“那么格西，你是奴隶主的后代吗？如果是，你是怎么从中获益的？”不，那听起来太像法拉汗那一套了。
I had to go someplace. I had to go someplace where I could concentrate, put it all on paper, so that it could sound perfect, like it was just another matter-of-fact question out of curiosity. I couldn't make them think I was some kind of overly sensitive black guy who couldn't take the past for what it was.
我得去个地方。我得去个地方集中精力，把这一切写在纸上，这样它听起来才完美，就像是出于好奇的一个顺便问起的问题。我不能让他们以为我是那种过于敏感、不能客观对待过去的黑人。
An older man with an intellectual face, the beard and glasses, raised his hand. And I thought, "Well, here's a guy who looks like a professor. He probably sees that there's a black guy here. Maybe we should ask the most important question." He cleared his throat, stroked his beard, and asked his question. "How the dickens did General Harding manage to keep the place so magnificently brilliant with all those horses?"
一个长着一张知识分子脸、留着胡子戴着眼镜的老年人举起了手。我想，“嗯，这个看起来像教授的家伙。他大概能看到这里有个黑人。也许我们应该问问最重要的那个问题。”他清了清嗓子，抚摸着胡须，问出了他的问题。“哈丁将军究竟是怎么在养着那么多马的情况下，把这个地方维持得如此辉煌的？”
I didn't know what to say. So I left the group and went to the next room to prepare my question, the question that was going to end this tour. I needed to concentrate.
我不知道该说什么。所以我离开了小组，走到下一个房间准备我的问题，那个终结这次参观的问题。我需要专注。
I carried Ivy into the next room, closed my eyes, and I thought. "Well, Gussie, you never mentioned anything about slaves. Did Nat Turner ever visit your plantation?" "Gussie, where did the slaves eat? Where did they sleep?" "Gussie, did you ever see the movie Mandingo? The part where Ken Norton sleeps with the master's wife?" "You ever tried to do a field holler?" Or "Gussie, who invented the blues?"
我抱着艾薇走进下一个房间，闭上眼睛思考。“嗯，格西，你从没提到过关于奴隶的任何事情。纳特·特纳（黑人奴隶起义领袖）有没有访问过你们的种植园？”“格西，奴隶们在哪里吃饭？在哪里睡觉？”“格西，你看过电影《曼丁哥》吗？就是肯·诺顿和主人妻子睡觉的那一段？”“你试过田间呼号吗？”或者，“格西，谁发明了蓝调？”
Suddenly, they all entered the room. "How's the baby?" Gussie asked. Immediately following her was Lucy, snapping pictures of the beautiful chandelier that hung like a giant earring from the ceiling. "Enjoying yourself?" she asked. "Isn't this beautiful?"
突然，他们全都进屋了。“宝宝怎么样？”格西问。紧随其后的是露西，正在拍天花板上像巨大耳环一样悬挂着的漂亮吊灯。“玩得开心吗？”她问。“这儿不美吗？”
Suddenly, I realized that Lucy, my dear wife, was one of them. God save us. I took a deep breath and waited for my moment, my question, my reasons for being. Not even sure what I was going to say, I raised my hand. Gussie looked my way.
突然，我意识到露西，我亲爱的妻子，是他们的一员。上帝保佑我们。我深吸一口气，等待着我的时刻、我的问题、我存在的理由。甚至不确定我要说什么，我举起了手。格西向我看来。
I could hear the voices of my ancestors telling me to keep going. "Go, Marvin. Go, Marvin. Go, original black man." All the injustices of the black race were now on my shoulders. My responsibility was clear. Gussie paused before pointing to me. We locked eyes.
我能听到祖先的声音在告诉我坚持下去。“加油，马文。加油，马文。加油，真正的黑人。”黑人种族所有的不公正现在都在我肩上。我的责任很明确。格西在点我之前停顿了一下。我们对视了。
And then Ivy let out the most ferocious scream she had ever made in her short life. "Why-- What--" I couldn't get it out. Ivy continued to sob and cry out piercing yells. It must have sounded like we were trying to kidnap her.
然后艾薇发出了她短暂一生中最凶猛的尖叫声。“为什么——什么——”我没能说出口。艾薇继续抽泣，发出尖锐的哭声。听起来一定像是我们试图绑架她。
"Let's go," I said. And like a team of emergency paramedics, we were out that door. The sun shined like lemon skins. And Ivy returned back to her smiley-faced innocence.
“我们走吧，”我说。就像一队紧急医护人员，我们冲出了那扇门。阳光像柠檬皮一样闪耀。而艾薇又恢复了她微笑的纯真。
I still don't know what've been the right thing for me to do at the Belle Meade. I couldn't tell if I was supposed to be a militant, arty Afrocentric or a well-adjusted, integrated black guy. And one day, when Ivy gets into one of these situations, I'm not quite sure what advice I'd give her.
我仍然不知道在贝尔米德庄园我该做什么才是对的。我看不出我是应该做一个好斗的、有艺术气息的非洲中心主义者，还是一个适应良好、融入主流的黑人。而且有一天，当艾薇遇到这种情况时，我不确定我会给她什么建议。
A few hours later, after we visit the Belle Meade, I made Lucy go with me this time to the Ernest Tubb Record Store. I've always liked country music. In fact, you could say country music was a part of my life, if you could believe that.
几小时后，参观完贝尔米德庄园，这次我让露西陪我去恩尼·塔布唱片店。我一直很喜欢乡村音乐。事实上，如果你相信的话，你可以说乡村音乐是我生活的一部分。
So in the Ernest Tubb store, for some reason, I wanted to show the good old boys that I knew a little something about country music, too. So I asked him. I asked him about an obscure and eccentric fiddle player named Stringbean. Neither one of the clerks seemed impressed.
所以在恩尼·塔布商店里，出于某种原因，我想向那些老乡展示我也懂一点乡村音乐。所以我问了。我问了他关于一个叫“四季豆”（Stringbean）的晦涩而古怪的琴手。两个店员似乎都没被打动。
And while I talked to one of them, the other one handed Ivy a Confederate flag to play with. Maybe he was trying to be friendly. Maybe he was trying to be nice. Sometimes I think I'm a bit too sensitive about all this race stuff. But maybe, maybe he was trying to send me a message. Maybe he knew exactly how I feel about the old Stars and Bars.
当我跟其中一个说话时，另一个递给艾薇一面邦联旗玩。也许他是想表示友好。也许他是想表现得友善。有时我觉得我对这些种族问题太敏感了。但也许，也许他是想给我传达个信息。也许他很清楚我对那面老星条旗的感觉。
I don't know about these situations. Lucy and I headed out the door, arm in arm, our baby happily waving the Confederate flag.
我对这些情况真是不知所措。露西和我手挽手走出店门，我们的宝宝快乐地挥舞着邦联旗。
Marvin Tate is a performer and a poet living here in Chicago.
马文·泰特是一位居住在芝加哥的表演者和诗人。
Coming up, David Sedaris on the golf course, the news story to end all news stories, and more, in a minute when our program continues.
稍后，大卫·塞达里斯将谈谈高尔夫球场、结束所有新闻故事的那则新闻，以及更多内容，稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a wide variety of writers, performers, and documentary producers to take a whack at that theme with radio monologues, original reporting, found tape, anything they can think of. Today's program, Your Dream, My Nightmare, stories of people simply not agreeing on what is good at some fundamental human level.
这是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和纪录片制片人通过广播独白、原创报道、现成录音等他们能想到的方式来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《你的梦想，我的噩梦》，讲述的是人们在某些基本人类层面上对什么是好的无法达成一致的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three, Motion. Well, while putting this show together this week, I picked up one of the local papers here in Chicago, and I realized that nearly every story on the front page was a narrative basically along the themes of your dream, my nightmare. I have the paper here.
我们来到了第三幕，《运动》。嗯，本周制作这档节目时，我拿起芝加哥的一份当地报纸，我意识到头版上的几乎每一个故事，基本都是关于“你的梦想，我的噩梦”这一主题。报纸就在这儿。
The lead story is about the transit authority here in Chicago phasing out subway train conductors. Taxpayers' dream, saving $4 million a year. Train conductors' nightmare. Just below that story, a piece about Rupert Murdoch achieving one of his many dreams, I assume, making his own sports cable network. ESPN's nightmare.
头条新闻是关于芝加哥交通管理局正在逐步淘汰地铁列车员。纳税人的梦想，每年节省400万美元。地铁列车员的噩梦。在那条新闻下面，是一篇关于鲁伯特·默多克实现他众多梦想之一的文章，我想是的，建立他自己的体育有线电视网。这是ESPN的噩梦。
To the left of that, with a very odd, I have to say, picture of Hillary Clinton kind of holding her fingers together in one of those little church shapes, her fingertips touching, looking both pious and extremely nervous, there's a story about one of Kenneth Starr's dreams and her nightmares. She has to turn over notes of her conversations with lawyers to the Whitewater independent counsel, and so forth, and so on. You get the idea.
在它的左边，有一张希拉里·克林顿相当古怪的照片，我要说，她双手合十做成那种小教堂形状，指尖相触，看起来既虔诚又极度紧张，这是一个关于肯·肯尼斯·斯塔尔梦想和她噩梦的故事。她必须把她与律师谈话的记录移交给白水事件的独立检察官，诸如此类。你懂的。
Well, Jay Allison is a seasoned newsman, does stories for ABC's Nightline and for all sorts of big public radio programs. And a while back, he realized that all the stories he was doing basically boiled down to one plot line, told over and over in various ways with different characters. Someone, somewhere, had the dream of moving to a new neighborhood. And that dream was somebody else's nightmare. Well, after he figured this out, he took the taped interviews he'd gathered on a number of stories, and he concocted this composite story to prove his point.
嗯，杰伊·艾利森是一位经验丰富的新闻人，为ABC的《夜线》和各种大型公共广播节目做报道。不久前，他意识到他所做的所有报道本质上都归结为一个故事情节，用不同的角色一遍又一遍地讲述。某人，在某地，梦想搬到一个新的社区。而那个梦想却是别人的噩梦。好吧，在他意识到这一点后，他把他为多个故事收集的采访录音剪辑在一起，编写了这个综合故事来证明他的观点。
It started up last night. I had taken the kids to the carnival, and we all got back around 9:00. And I wanted to water the lawn before I went to bed, but Artie Davis had borrowed the sprinkler. So I went across the street to get it back from him, and I saw the light was on in his garage. Inside were Artie and his wife, June, Sam Lawson, and Reverend James. They were talking about the new people in the neighborhood, and they were pretty worked up.
事情是从昨晚开始的。我带孩子们去了嘉年华，我们9点左右才回来。睡觉前我想给草坪浇水，但阿蒂·戴维斯借走了洒水器。所以我穿过街道去拿回来，看到他车库里的灯亮着。里面是阿蒂和他的妻子琼、萨姆·劳森，还有詹姆斯牧师。他们在谈论社区里的新邻居，而且他们很激动。
The people in this town just don't want 'em here. They want 'em out. And from the word that's around, they'll do about anything to get 'em out.
镇上的人就是不想要他们在这儿。他们想让他们滚。据传言，为了把他们赶走，他们什么都做得出来。
Everyone was upset. They had been since these people moved in two weeks ago. Sam Lawson said there was no reason we had to put up with this. He said, "These people are freaks." He called them "garbage."
每个人都很沮丧。自从两周前这些人搬进来以来，情况一直如此。萨姆·劳森说我们没有理由忍受这个。他说：“这些人是怪胎。”他称他们为“垃圾”。
They're garbage.
他们是垃圾。
"They're just garbage," he said.
“他们就是垃圾，”他说。
They're just garbage. And there's no reason that garbage like that has got to intimidate decent people because they think they're defenseless.
他们就是垃圾。没理由让那种垃圾恐吓体面的人，因为他们认为我们是手无缚鸡之力的。
And even Reverend James didn't have a kind word to say about these new people.
甚至连詹姆斯牧师也没说这些新人的好话。
Ignorant, repulsive, and evil.
无知、令人厌恶，而且邪恶。
And we just don't want 'em here. And that's what it's all about. Get 'em out of here. They don't belong here, and we don't want 'em here.
我们就是不想要他们在这里。事情就是这样。让他们滚出去。他们不属于这里，我们不想要他们在这里。
Well, this afternoon, things hadn't calmed down too much. The whole neighborhood was on edge about these new people. Artie Davis said they didn't scare him, but they scared his wife.
嗯，今天下午，情况还没平息。整个社区都因为这些新人而紧张不安。阿蒂·戴维斯说他们吓不到他，但吓到了他妻子。
They don't frighten me, but they do her.
他们吓不到我，但能吓到她。
Artie said his wife, June, had a dream about these freaks last night. And he wasn't gonna stand for it. In June's dream, one of these freaks tried to make June look into his eyes.
阿蒂说他妻子琼昨晚梦见这些怪胎了。他可忍不了。在琼的梦里，其中一个怪胎试图让琼直视他的眼睛。
--to get me to look in his eyes. And I wouldn't do it because his eyes were real--
——想让我盯着他的眼睛看。我没敢，因为他的眼睛实在——
But June wouldn't do it because the whites in his eyes were real big.
但琼没敢那样做，因为他眼睛里的眼白实在太大。
--the whites in his eyes were real big, and they were shiny.
——他眼白实在太大，而且闪闪发光。
And they were shiny, like the devil's or something.
而且闪闪发光，就像魔鬼的一样。
Early this evening, the four of us gathered at my place to decide what to do. June stayed home because, Artie said, she was frightened. All day long, Artie and Sam had patrolled outside the house the freaks moved into. And the freaks never came out. They just stayed inside, which was strange in itself. Reverend James arrived around 8 o'clock. He was still upset about the situation.
今天傍晚，我们四个人聚集在我家商量对策。琼待在家里，因为阿蒂说，她很害怕。整整一天，阿蒂和萨姆都在那些怪胎搬进去的房子外巡逻。但他们从没出来过。他们只是待在里面，这本身就很奇怪。詹姆斯牧师8点左右到了。他还是很心烦。
It's disgusting.
太恶心了。
But he had an idea.
但他有个主意。
I would get me 100 good men, give them each a baseball bat, and dare one of these freaks to stick his head over the edge of the sidewalk.
我要找100个好汉，每人发一根棒球棍，看有哪个怪胎敢把头探出人行道边上。
Well, that didn't sound too bad. But the rest of us couldn't figure out where we could come up with 100 men.
嗯，这听起来还不坏。但我们其他人想不出能去哪找100个人。
Men? Listen, I know at least 500 men who would be only too happy to serve. Happen to be all Christians in my church that I had in mind.
男人？听着，我认识至少500个乐于效劳的人。碰巧我心里想的都是我教会里的基督徒。
Still, we wondered if 500 men were really necessary.
尽管如此，我们还是怀疑是否真的需要500人。
Then make it 25. Make it 10 men. Make it five men.
那就25人。10个人。5个人。
So we talked it over and decided that just the four of us could take care of things by ourselves. On our way, we stopped by and told June what we were going to do.
所以我们商量了一下，决定我们四个人就能自己解决问题。在路上，我们停下来告诉琼我们要去做什么。
I feel like I'm sitting on pins and needles just waiting.
我感觉就像如坐针毡，一直在等结果。
Then we checked to see that we had everything we needed.
然后我们检查了一下是否带齐了所有需要的东西。
All we need is some good old-fashioned guts and morals.
我们只需要一些老派的勇气和道德。
And so at 10 o'clock, we marched on over to the freaks' house. We were ready for anything. From our position in their front yard, we could see them moving around inside their house. We tried everything we could think of. I think they knew we weren't kidding around this time. But they wouldn't come outside.
于是10点钟，我们向怪胎们的房子进军。我们做好了万全准备。在他们前院的位置，我们能看到他们在屋里走来走去。我们尝试了能想到的一切办法。我想他们知道我们这次不是开玩笑。但他们就是不出来。
Sam thought maybe we should try setting fire to the place or something. But Reverend James pointed out that that would be destruction of property. So we waited. But by 12 o'clock, it started to get cold, and we were hungry. So we came on home.
萨姆想也许我们应该试着放火烧了房子之类的。但詹姆斯牧师指出那样会损毁财产。所以我们等了等。但到了12点，天冷了，我们也饿了。于是我们回了家。
But tomorrow night, we're going back. June says she'll pack some food for us to take along. Sam's bringing his portable TV set and some blankets. Reverend James is bringing the baseball bats again. And I'm bringing the beer.
但明天晚上，我们还要去。琼说她会为我们打包些食物带着。萨姆要带上他的便携式电视机和毯子。詹姆斯牧师要再带上棒球棍。而我要带上啤酒。
Jay Allison's story is part of his series Life Stories produced with Tina Egloff.
杰伊·艾利森的这个故事是他与蒂娜·埃格洛夫制作的系列节目《生活故事》的一部分。
Act Four, Blood. Well, some of the biggest your-dream-my-nightmare situations happen between parents and children. One of the central tensions, I believe, between parents and their adult kids is the adult children not living up to their parents' dreams for what they should have turned into and who they should have been.
第四幕，《血缘》。嗯，一些最大的“你的梦想，我的噩梦”场景发生在父母与孩子之间。我认为父母与成年子女之间核心的紧张关系之一，就是成年子女没有活成父母心目中他们应该成为的样子，也没有变成父母期待的人。
In this light, thinking about our show this week, I realized this about my own family, that, when I was a kid, my mom had this dream for my older sister. She wanted my older sister to play the piano. My older sister was actually really wonderful at playing the piano. But my mom really thought she could be a professional.
从这个角度思考本周的节目，关于我自己的家庭，我意识到这一点：当我还是个孩子时，我妈妈对我姐姐有个梦想。她想让我姐姐弹钢琴。我姐姐弹钢琴确实非常棒。但我妈妈真的认为她能成为职业选手。
And my mom's dream for me was-- if she had to articulate it, I think she would have said-- and she did say sometimes-- that she wanted me to be a doctor. Neither thing really worked out. My sister went to business school. Here I am.
而我妈妈对我的梦想是——如果非要说出来，我想她会说——她确实有时也说过——她想让我成为一名医生。这两样最终都没成真。我姐姐读了商学院。而我在这里。
And as it turned out, as my mom got older, she became a doctor. She's a psychologist now. And just recently, in the last two years, she started playing the piano, too.
结果正如后来那样，随着妈妈年纪大了，她自己成了医生。她现在是个心理学家。就在最近，这两年，她也开始弹钢琴了。
Well, not everybody is lucky to have parents who basically transfer their own dream back onto themselves and off the kids. One of those people is David Sedaris. He has this story of parents and children.
嗯，并不是每个人都那么幸运，父母能把自己的梦想转移回自己身上，而不是强加给孩子。大卫·塞达里斯就是其中之一。他有一个关于父母和孩子的故事。
My sister, Lisa, became a woman on the 14th hole of the Pinehurst golf course. That's what she was told by the stranger who led her to the women's lounge. "Relax, sugar, you're a woman now."
我姐姐丽莎是在松树丛高尔夫球场的第14洞长大的。这是那个带她去女士休息室的陌生人告诉她的。“放松点，亲爱的，你现在是女人了。”
We had gone unwittingly, shanghaied by our father who had offered to take Lisa and I for a ride in the second-hand Porsche he'd recently bought. His sherbet-colored pants should have tipped us off. But seeing as there were no golf clubs in the backseat, we thought we were safe. There was nothing worse than spending an afternoon on the golf course, especially for Lisa, who was troubled that day by unexplained cramps.
我们是在不知情的情况下被父亲骗去的，他提出要带我和丽莎去坐他刚买的二手保时捷。他那冰糕色的裤子本该提醒我们。但鉴于后座没有高尔夫球杆，我们以为很安全。没有什么比在下午去高尔夫球场更糟的了，尤其是对丽莎来说，那天她还正被莫名其妙的痛经折磨。
"Just a short, little jaunt," my father said. He folded back the car's canvas roof and crouched into the driver's seat. "Hell, maybe we'll just tool up to the fairgrounds and back. Maybe we'll go get ourselves some ice cream. Who knows?"
“只是个短程小游，”我父亲说。他折回车顶的帆布蓬，缩进驾驶座。“见鬼，也许我们只是开车去集市再转回来。也许我们去吃点冰淇淋。谁知道呢？”
The map, the nervous glances at his watch. It soon became apparent that this was no joy ride. Our father knew exactly where we were headed and had it planned so that we'd arrive just in time for the tee off.
地图，他紧张地盯着手表。很快就显而易见，这根本不是什么兜风。我父亲完全知道我们要去哪里，并且计划好了让我们刚好赶上开球时间。
"Well, what do you know?" he said, pulling off the road and into the crowded golf course parking lot. "I wonder if there's not some kind of a tournament taking place. What do you say we take a quick peek? Gosh, this is a beautiful place. Wait'll you get a look at these fairways."
“好吧，谁会想到呢？”他说着，把车开离公路，进入了拥挤的高尔夫球场停车场。“不知道是不是有什么锦标赛正在进行。你说我们要不要过去瞥一眼？天哪，这地方真美。等着瞧瞧这些球道。”
Lisa and I groaned, cursing our stupidity. Once again, we'd been tricked. We knew what was in store for us and understood that the next few hours would pass like days or maybe even weeks. Our watches would yawn, the minute hand pausing to nap before sluggishly completing its rounds.
丽莎和我 groaned（发出了呻吟），咒骂自己的愚蠢。我们又被骗了。我们知道等待我们的是什么，也明白接下来的几个小时会像几天甚至几周一样漫长。我们的手表会打哈欠，分针在懒洋洋地完成绕行前会先停下来打个盹。
First, our father would push us to the front of a large, gaily-dressed crowd. Robbed of their choice spots, these spectators would huff and grumble, whispering insults we would pretend not to hear. "They're kids," my father would say. "What do you want them to do, stand on my shoulders? Come on now, pal, have a heart."
首先，父亲会把我们推到一大群衣着鲜艳的观众前面。由于失去了好的观赏位置，这些观众会发火抱怨，窃窃私语着我们假装听不见的侮辱。“他们是孩子，”我父亲会说。“你们想让他们怎么着，站在我肩膀上吗？拜托了，老兄，发发善心吧。”
The big boys were playing that day, men whose names we recognized from the magazines my father kept stacked beside the toilet and heaped in the backseat of his car. We'd seen these players on television and heard their strengths and weaknesses debated by the maniacs who frequented the pro shop of our country club. Seeing the pros in person was no more interesting than eating an ice-cold hamburger. But it meant the world to our father, who hoped their presence might kindle a passion, inciting us to take up our clubs and strive for excellence. This was, for him, an act of love, a misguided attempt to enrich our lives and bring us closer together as a family.
大人物们那天正在打球，名字我们都能从父亲堆在马桶边、塞满后座的杂志上认出来。我们在电视上见过这些选手，听过在那家乡村俱乐部的职业商店里常客们的各种强弱论调。亲眼看这些职业选手并不比吃一个冰凉的汉堡更有趣。但这对我父亲意义重大，他希望他们的出现能点燃我们的激情，激励我们拿起球杆，追求卓越。对他而言，这是一种爱，一种试图丰富我们生活、使我们一家人更加亲密的误导性尝试。
"You kids are so damn lucky," he said, placing his hands on our shoulders. "These are the best players in the PGA. And here you are with front-row seats." "What seats?" Lisa asked. "Where?"
“你们这些孩子真是太幸运了，”他说着，把手放在我们肩上。“这些是PGA最好的选手。而你们在这里拥有前排座位。”“什么座位？”丽莎问。“在哪？”
We stood on the grassy embankment, watching as the first player teed off. "Lisa," my father whispered. "Go get it. Go get Snead's tee." When Lisa refused, it was up to me to wander onto the green, searching for the spent wooden peg that might have traveled anywhere from 6 to 20 feet from its original position.
我们站在草坡上，看着第一个选手开球。“丽莎，”父亲低声说。“去把它捡回来。去捡斯尼德的球座。”当丽莎拒绝时，只能由我去球道上溜达，搜寻那个可能从原位置飞出6到20英尺远的木制球座。
Our father collected these tees as good-luck charms and kept them stored in the goldfish bowl which sat upon his dresser. It was forbidden to wander onto the course during a tournament, so our father sent us to do his dirty work, hoping the officials might see us as enthusiastic upstarts, who decorated our rooms with posters of the masters working their way out of sand traps or hoisting a trophy after a stunning victory at Pebble Beach. Nothing could have been farther from the truth.
父亲收集这些球座作为幸运符，存放在梳妆台上的金鱼缸里。在比赛期间溜进球场是禁止的，所以父亲派我们去做这种下作事，希望官员们可能把我们看作是那种会在房间挂着大师们在沙坑里挣扎或是夺冠后举起奖杯的海报、充满热情的年轻追随者。事实恰恰相反。
No matter how hard he tried to motivate us, the members of my family refused to take even the slightest interest in what was surely the dullest game ever invented. We despised golf and everything that went with it, from the ridiculous tam-o'-shanters right down to the cruel spiked shoes.
无论他如何努力激励我们，我家人拒绝哪怕对这项被公认为史上最枯燥的游戏表现出一丝兴趣。我们厌恶高尔夫以及与之相关的一切，从荒谬的苏格兰无檐帽一直到残酷的钉鞋。
"Oh, Lou," my mother would whine, dressed for a cocktail party in her muted, earth-tone caftan. "You're not going to wear that, are you?" "What's wrong with this?" he'd ask. "These pants are brand new." "New to you," she'd say. "Pimps and circus clowns have been dressing that way for years."
“噢，卢，”我母亲会抱怨道，她穿着一身柔和大地色调的长袍，正准备去参加鸡尾酒会。“你不会穿成那样出门吧？”“这身怎么了？”他会问。“裤子是全新的。”“对你来说是新的，”她说。“皮条客和马戏团小丑很多年前就这么穿了。”
We never understood how a man who took such pride in his sober, tailored suits could spend his weekends in Day-Glo pants patterned with singing tree frogs or wee kilted Scotsmen. You needed sunglasses in order to open his closet door, what with all the candy-colored sweaters, aggressive madras sports coats, and painfully bright polo shirts all screaming for attention.
我们从没搞懂，一个以稳重、量身定做的西装为荣的人，怎么会在周末穿那种印有歌唱树蛙或穿短裙小苏格兰人图案的荧光裤子。为了打开他的衣柜门，你需要戴上太阳镜，里面全是糖果色的毛衣、张扬的马德拉斯运动外套，以及令人痛苦的明亮马球衫，它们都在尖叫着吸引注意力。
"I don't feel so well," Lisa whispered to my father, as we marched from the sand trap to the putting green of the eighth hole. "I really think we need to leave."
“我感觉不太好，”当我们在第八洞从沙坑走向果岭时，丽莎对我父亲耳语道。“我觉得我们真的需要离开。”
My father ignored her. "If Trevino bogeys this hole, he's screwed. That last bunker shot pinned his ass right to the wall. Did you see his backswing?" "I'm concerned right now about my back," Lisa said. "It's aching, and I want to go home and lie down." "We'll be just another minute," my father said.
父亲无视了她。“如果特维诺这一洞打出柏忌，他就完蛋了。刚才那个沙坑球把他逼到了死角。你看到他的回杆了吗？”“我现在关心的是我的后背，”丽莎说。“它很痛，我想回家躺下。”“再等一分钟就好，”父亲说。
He fingered the collection of tees in his pocket. "The problem with you kids is that you're not paying enough attention to the game. First thing tomorrow morning, I'm signing you up for some more lessons. Then you'll see what I'm talking about. Jesus, this game is just so exciting, you won't be able to stand it."
他摆弄着口袋里收集的球座。“你们这些孩子的问题就是对比赛不够专心。明天一早，我就给你们报名多上几节课。到时你就知道我在说什么了。耶稣，这游戏实在是太刺激了，你根本无法抗拒。”
We had serious doubts that it was exciting, but he was right when he said we wouldn't be able to stand it. The driving range, the putt-putt courses-- he just didn't get it. We didn't want advice on our swing. We only wanted to be left alone to practice witchcraft, or deface fashion dolls, or sit in the privacy of our rooms, fantasizing about anything other than golf.
我们严重怀疑它是否刺激，但他说的“无法抗拒”确实是真的。练习场，迷你高尔夫球道——他根本不懂。我们不需要关于挥杆的建议。我们只想独自待着去练习巫术，或者毁掉时尚玩偶，或者坐在房间的隐私里，幻想除高尔夫以外的任何事情。
98 degrees on the second hole, and we'd crumpled to the green, listening as children our own age shouted and splashed in the country club pool. The tournament dragged on. And by the time we reached the 14th hole, Lisa had begun to bleed, the rust-colored spot visible on her white culottes.
第二洞时温度有98华氏度，我们已经瘫倒在果岭上，听着和我们同龄的孩子在乡村俱乐部的游泳池里尖叫嬉水。比赛拖拖拉拉。当我们到达第14洞时，丽莎开始流血，白色阔腿裤上可见锈色的斑点。
She was close to tears, sunburned and frightened when she whispered something into my father's ear. "We'll just go get one of the gals," he said. "They'll take care of you." He turned to a handsome, white-haired woman, wearing a lime green visor in a skirt patterned with grinning pandas. "Hey, sweetheart, I'm wondering if you could help me out with a personal problem."
她快哭了，被晒伤了，受到惊吓，当时她在我父亲耳边耳语了一些话。“我们去找其中一个女士，”他说。“她们会照顾你的。”他转向一位漂亮的、白发苍苍的女性，她戴着青柠色的遮阳帽，穿着印有咧嘴笑熊猫图案的裙子。“嘿，亲爱的，我在想你能不能帮我处理个私人的问题。”
Like my father, this woman had followed these players from hole to hole, taking note of their every move. She had come out that day to bask in the glow of the masters. And now a strange man was asking her to accompany his daughter to the clubhouse and outfit her with a sanitary napkin. The woman nodded her head and, taking my sister's hand, reluctantly led her towards a distant cluster of buildings.
像我父亲一样，这个女人也跟着选手们从一个洞走到另一个洞，注意他们的一举一动。她那天出来就是为了沉浸在大师们的光芒中。而现在一个陌生男人却请她陪他女儿去会所，并给她配个卫生巾。女人点了点头，拉着我姐姐的手，勉强领着她走向远处的一群建筑。
I didn't understand the problem, but very much wanted to join them, thinking perhaps we might talk this person into giving us a ride home, away from this grinding tedium and the fierce, relentless sun. With Lisa gone, it would become my sole responsibility to fetch the splintered golf tees and pester the contestants for their autographs. "Lou," I would say, holding out my father's scorecard. "My name is Lou."
我不明白是什么问题，但非常想加入她们，心想也许我们能说服这个人送我们回家，远离这磨人的乏味和猛烈无情的阳光。丽莎走了，捡碎掉的高尔夫球座并缠着选手要签名的重任就成了我一个人的责任。“卢，”我会说，举起父亲的记分卡。“我叫卢。”
The game finally over, we returned to the parking lot to find Lisa stretched out on the backseat of the Porsche, her face and lap covered with golf towels. "Don't say it," she threatened. "Whatever it is, I don't want to hear it." "All I was gonna do was ask you to take your lousy feet off the car," my father said. "Yeah? Well, why don't you just go [BLEEP] yourself?"
比赛终于结束了，我们回到停车场，发现丽莎躺在保时捷的后座上，脸和腿上盖着高尔夫毛巾。“别说出来，”她威胁道。“不管是什么，我都不想听。”“我本来只是想叫你把那双讨厌的脚从车上拿下来，”我父亲说。“是吗？那为什么你不去[哔——]你自己呢？”
The moment she said it, Lisa bolted upright as if there still might be time to catch the word between her teeth before it reached our father's ears. None of us had ever spoken to him that way. And now he would have no choice but to kill her. Some unprecedented threshold had been passed. And even the crickets stopped their singing, stunned into silence by the word which hung in the air like a cloud of spent gunpowder.
在那句话说出的瞬间，丽莎猛地坐直，好像如果能赶在话音传进父亲耳朵前收回来还来得及似的。我们从没那样对他说话。而现在他别无选择，只能杀掉她。一个前所未有的门槛被跨过了。甚至连蟋蟀都停止了鸣叫，被那悬浮在空气中如云团般的废火药味儿似的字眼震惊到静默。
My father sighed and shook his head in disappointment. This was the same way he reacted to my mother when anger and frustration caused her to forget herself. Lisa was not a daughter now, but just another woman unable to control her wildly shifting emotions. "Don't mind her," he said, wiping a thin coat of pollen off the windshield. "She's just having lady problems."
父亲叹了口气，失望地摇了摇头。这和他母亲发火或沮丧导致忘乎所以时，他的反应一模一样。丽莎现在不是个女儿，只是又一个无法控制情绪波动的女人。“别管她，”他说着，擦掉挡风玻璃上薄薄的一层花粉。“她只是有女人的麻烦。”
Throughout the years, our father has continued his campaign to interest us in the sport of golf. When Gretchen, Amy, and Tiffany rejected his advances, he placed his hopes in our brother Paul, who found the sprawling greens an excellent place to enjoy a hit of acid and overturn the golf carts he stole from the parking lot beside the pro shop.
多年来，父亲一直坚持不懈地试图让我们对高尔夫产生兴趣。当格雷琴、艾米和蒂芙尼拒绝他的示好时，他把希望寄托在我们弟弟保罗身上，后者觉得广阔的果岭是个吸毒和翻倒他从职业商店停车场偷来的高尔夫球车的好地方。
He bought a wide-screen TV, an enormous model the size of an industrial-sized washing machine, and uses it only to watch and record his beloved tournaments. The top of the set is stacked high with videocassettes marked "'94 PGA" and "'89 US Open-- Unbelievable."
他买了一台宽屏电视，一个工业洗衣机大小的巨大型号，只用它来看和录下他挚爱的锦标赛。电视机顶部堆满了标记着“94年PGA”和“89年美国公开赛——不可思议”的录像带。
Before our mother died, she put together a videotape she thought Lisa might enjoy. The two of them had spent a great deal of time in the kitchen, drinking wine and watching old movies on the black-and-white portable television that sat beside the sink. These were just a few favorites my mother had recorded. "No big deal," she'd said, "just a little something to watch one day when you're bored."
母亲去世前，她制作了一盘她认为丽莎会喜欢的录像带。她们两人曾在厨房花了很多时间，边喝酒边看着水槽边那台黑白便携式电视播放的老电影。这些只是母亲录下的一些最爱。“没什么大不了的，”她曾说，“只是当你无聊时可以看的一点小东西。”
A few weeks after the funeral, Lisa searched my parents' house for the tape, finding it on the downstairs bar beside my father's chair. She carried the cassette home, but found she needed a bit more time before watching it. For Lisa, these movies would recall private times, just her and her mother perched on stools and reeling off the names of each actor as they appeared on the screen. These memories would be a gift that Lisa preferred to savor before opening.
葬礼几周后，丽莎在父母家里寻找那盘带子，在楼下父亲椅子旁边的吧台上找到了。她把录像带带回家，但发现她在观看前需要更多时间。对丽莎来说，这些电影会勾起私人时光，只有她和母亲并坐在凳子上，随着屏幕上演员的出现大声说出他们的名字。这些记忆是一份礼物，丽莎更愿意在打开前先细细品味。
She waited until the initial grief had passed and then, settling onto her sofa with a tray of snacks, she slipped in the tape, delighted to find that it began with Double Indemnity. The opening credits were rolling when suddenly the video skipped and shifted to color. It was a man squatting on his heels and peering down the shaft of his putter as though it  were a rifle. Behind him stood a multitude of spectators shaded by tall pines, their faces tan and wrapped in concentration. "Greg Norman's bogeyed all three par-fives," the announcer whispered. "But if he eagles here on the 15th, he's still got a shot at the Masters."
她等到最初的悲痛过去，然后坐在沙发上，端着一盘零食，插进带子，很高兴发现它以《双重赔偿》开头。开场字幕正滚动时，视频突然跳跃并切换到彩色。那是一个男人蹲在脚后跟上，正像瞄准步枪一样盯着他的推杆杆身。在他身后站着一群被高大松树遮住的观众，他们面孔晒成棕色，全神贯注。播音员轻声说：“格雷格·诺曼三个五杆洞都打出柏忌。但如果他在这里的第15洞打出老鹰球，他依然有机会争夺大师赛。”
David Sedaris's story "Women's Open" is from his new book of autobiographical stories called Naked. His latest play opens as part of the Lincoln Center Festival July 8. It's called Incident at Cobbler's Knob.
大卫·塞达里斯的故事“女子公开赛”出自他名为《赤裸》的自传式故事新书。他的最新剧作将于7月8日作为林肯中心艺术节的一部分上演。剧名叫《鞋匠旋钮事件》。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. Musical help today from John Connors and Sarah Vowell. Original musical scoring during Marvin Tate's story by LeRoy Bach and C.J. Bani. To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德协助。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·塔夫。感谢约翰·康纳斯和莎拉·沃威尔提供的音乐支持。马文·泰特故事期间的原创音乐由勒罗伊·巴赫和C.J.巴尼配乐。要购买本节目的录像带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，号码是312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who turned to me after our first time on the air and said--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他在我们第一次播出后转过身对我说道——
Relax, sugar, you're a woman now.
放松点，亲爱的，你现在是女人了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这一美国生活》的故事。